Let's see, our next question is from Joanne S. from Toronto, Ontario who's asking,...
..."Why is the food at McDonald's so cheap?"
Well, hi Joanne, I'm John Betts, president of McDonald's here in Canada.
You ask a great question.
And if you think about when you go out and shop for the family,...
...when you buy those large containers with lots of whatever it is that you're buying,...
...you know you can often get them at a cheaper price...
...because you're buying in bulk.
Well, when you buy for 1400 restaurants in Canada,...
...you get some great deals that we love to pass along to our customers.
Last year, we bought 70 million pounds of ground beef,...
...65 million Canadian grade A eggs.
That's a lot of buying power.
We're buying from some of the great suppliers that you have an opportunity to buy from here in Canada as well,...
...such as Renee's, Cargill, Saputo, Coke, Heinz, and many more.
The opportunity to pass along these savings to our customers is one of the things that we pride ourselves at McDonald's.
It's about providing great quality, great tasting food at a great value.
And when you buy in bulk like we do, you can pass along the savings and that's exactly what we do.
Thanks for the question, Joanne!